Ich werde mich um ihre Becher werden können, aber vor allem für ihre Personen, die sich da hat, erfassen.
Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Britta Ort.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Fortnachname langsam ustebiren?
Britta ist ein weiblicher Vorname.
Frau Ort, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin genau 68 Jahre alt.
1860.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
25. Mai, 1900.
Bitte.
1957.
Ja, genau.
Danke.
1957.
Ich heiße mich 900.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
98 kg.
Okay.
Was für ein Sieg für uns, Frau Ort?
Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft.
Und ich kann nicht mehr laufen.
Was meinen Sie?
Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft.
Und ich kann nicht laufen.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Eigentlich habe ich diese Beschwerden immer ein bisschen mehr.
Ich bin immer ein bisschen Luftnot.
Ich wiege ja auch nicht wenig.
Ich bin ja auch fast 100 kg schwer.
Aber das ist normal, weil ich so dick bin.
Aber jetzt ist die Luftnot schlechter geworden.
Seit 14 Tagen.
Was haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Engelgefühl bemerkt?
Brustschmerzen oder Engelgefühl nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, da ist ein Stein auf meiner Brust.
Stein?
Wie ein Stein auf meiner Brust.
Können Sie Flachliegen ohne Luftnot bekommen?
Zu bekommen.
Ohne Luftnot bekommen.
Flachliegen?
Was meinen Sie mit Flachliegen?
Ich liege auf zwei Kissen.
Ganz ohne Kissen.
Das geht nicht, Frau Doktor.
So kann ich nicht liegen.
Dann kriege ich keine Luft.
In Ruhe haben Sie Luftnot bekommen?
Komm nicht.
Haben Sie in Ruhe Luftnot?
Ja.
Jetzt?
Jetzt.
Wie lange dauert diese Beschwerden?
Dauren diese Beschwerden mehr Zeit.
Wie lange dauern diese Beschwerden?
Was meinen Sie mit wie lange?
Ich habe das immer.
Ich habe das durchgehend.
Haben Sie Husten bemerkt?
Ja.
Eine Reizhusten.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn ich Treppen steige und Flachliege habe.
Haben Sie eine Auswurf mit Husten?
Haben Sie eine Auswurf beim Husten?
Das geht.
Ja.
Wie ist nach Ihrem Schleim aus?
Ein Schleim, wie der aussieht, der ist weiß.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Schutulfros oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Nachtschweiß habe.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Kalte Schweiß?
Kalte Schweiß.
Ich schwitze immer, wenn ich mich anstrenge.
Okay.
Aber ich schwitze immer, Frau Doktor.
Wie bitte?
Ich wiege auch 100 kg.
Ich schwitze immer, wenn ich mich anstrenge.
Sie haben wieviel kg abgenommen?
Abgenommen.
Hab ich gesagt, dass ich abgenommen habe oder meinen Sie, ob ich abgenommen habe?
Ich habe nicht.
Wollen Sie mich fragen, ob ich abgenommen habe?
Ja, haben Sie.
Sie haben wieviel kg abgenommen heißt?
Sie haben abgenommen, wieviel haben Sie abgenommen?
Sie müssen sagen, haben Sie abgenommen?
Hab ich abgenommen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe zugenommen.
Zugenommen, ja.
Wieviel kg?
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Aber bestimmt 10 kg.
Das ging ganz schnell.
In den letzten paar Wochen habe ich 10 kg drauf.
Seit wann?
In den letzten paar Wochen kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber das ging ganz schnell.
Auf einmal hatte ich 10 kg mehr.
10 kg zugenommen?
Ja.
Hab ich Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Wie meinen Sie?
Ich habe noch eine gewarte Beine bemerkt.
Was ist gewarme?
Ich habe keine Beine.
Nicht, nicht.
Nein, okay.
Haben Sie überwärmte?
Überwärmte, ja.
Ich habe saueren Geschmack im Mund.
Moment, die letzte Frage habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ob ich was gemerkt habe?
Ob ich überwärmte was bemerkt habe?
Beine bemerkt.
Meine Beine sind dick, richtig dick.
Geschwolle, ne?
Ja, die sind dick, die Beine.
Die sind immer dicker, ich kann nicht mehr laufen,
so schwer sind meine Beine.
Seit wann?
Seit ein paar Wochen.
Ein paar Wochen.
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal eine Beschwerde?
Ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen Pause machen,
weil ich so viel Luftnot habe.
Ja.
Diese Beschwerden noch schon mal gehabt, meinen Sie?
Früher, nein.
Nein.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Gibt es bei Ihnen in letzter Zeit Verletzung im Brustkorb?
Gab es in letzter Zeit eine Verletzung im Brustkorb?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ob ich einen Unfall hatte?
Ja, Unfall hatte.
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Frau Doktor, Sie sehen ja, ich kriege kaum Luft.
Da kann man nicht gut essen.
Trotzdem nehme ich zu, verstehe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Wasserlassen?
Ich muss viel Wasser lassen.
Viel Wasser lassen?
Hab ich nicht.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie viel Wasser lassen?
Seit wann müssen Sie viel Wasser lassen?
Was tut man?
Oder seit wann haben Sie, nee, seit wann müssen Sie viel Wasser lassen?
Seit wann?
Das habe ich jetzt auch schon seit einigen Wochen.
Das ist immer so, seit ein paar Wochen ist das alles.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Farbveränderungen im Urin bemerkt?
Habt Veränderungen in meinem Urin? Nein.
Haben Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Wegen was? Wegen Stuhlgang oder wegen Wasserlassen?
Wegen Wasserlassen.
Tagsüber ist das gar nicht so viel, aber nachts muss ich sehr viel Wasser lassen.
Trinken Sie genug Wasser?
Ja, ich trinke eigentlich viel Wasser.
Ja, nachts müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen.
Müssen Sie nachts viel Wasser lassen?
Müssen Sie nicht um Wasser zu lassen?
Toilette gehen ist alles.
Stuhlgang, Toilette gehen ist Wasserlassen.
Müssen Sie nachts viel Wasser lassen?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt.
Müssen Sie nicht um Wasser zu lassen?
Okay.
Müssen Sie erbrechen?
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck,
Suckerkrankheit, Schüttrüse, Uberfunktion oder Unterfunktion?
Ja, ich habe Diabetes, dann nehme ich Tabletten.
Ich habe einen Bluthochdruck, dann nehme ich auch Tabletten.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich jetzt alle Tabletten im Kopf weiß.
Ich muss überlegen.
Und ich habe schon mal ein Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Diabetes mellitus?
Diabetes mellitus?
Das habe ich schon lange, das habe ich schon bestimmt zehn Jahre.
Zehn lange Jahre?
Ja.
Zehn lange Jahre nicht, zehn Jahre lang.
Zehn Jahre lang.
Okay.
Bluthochdruck seit wann?
Das habe ich auch schon lange, das habe ich auch schon zehn, zwölf Jahre.
Okay.
Hatten Sie Herzinfarkt?
Seit wann war das?
Wann war was?
Wann war Herzinfarkt?
Ach so, wann war der Herzinfarkt?
Der Herzinfarkt war vor, ich glaube fünf Jahren.
Wie wurden Sie behandelt?
Sie meinen, mein Herzinfarkt?
Ja.
Ich habe eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung bekommen.
Und die haben mir Stanz gesetzt in mein Herz.
Stanz behandelt?
Ja, ich habe Stanz bekommen damals.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gehen Sie eigentlich Medikamente ein?
Na ja, ich habe doch gesagt, ich habe Bluthochdruck, da nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Ich habe Diabetes, da nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Und ich hatte ein Herzinfarkt, da nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente dafür?
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Nehmen Sie ein.
Ich nehme das ASS ein, wegen meinem Herzinfarkt.
Dann muss ich jetzt überlegen, ich weiß, für mein Blutzucker nehme ich Medformin ein, 1000 Milligramm.
Da hatte ich eine, jetzt nehme ich zwei ein, morgens und abends.
Ja.
Und dann noch, wie heißt denn das Medikament?
Was gegen Cholesterin?
Cholesterin.
Attervastatin heißt das, glaube ich, 40 Milligramm, abends eine.
Dann nehme ich ein, lassen Sie mich mal überlegen, ich muss jetzt das Medikament erstmal überlegen, was ich einnehme.
Bluthochdruck, was nehmen Sie?
Ja, ich überlege gerade, wegen meinem Bluthochdruck.
Ich glaube, es heißt am Lodipin, da nehme ich 5 Milligramm morgens und abends eine ein.
Und dann noch ein Ramipril, 5 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Okay.
Sonst noch?
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Sind bein in allerginen oder unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Das worden. Ich hatte die Herzkatheteruntersuchung.
Ja, Herzkatheter ist nicht Operation, ein Grief.
Ja, ich hatte nur eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung, sonst nichts.
Okay, okay.
Sind bein in allerginen oder unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Allergieren.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, ich habe bis vor meinem Herzenfakt, vor 5 Jahren, habe ich geraucht.
Wie lange habe ich geraucht?
25 Jahre habe ich bestimmt geraucht.
Hört man, ist es im Sesimi gelmiyor?
Gelmiyor, es gibt es manchmal.
Öle? Scheiben, Kleister.
25 Jahre?
Ungefähr.
Okay.
Wie viel Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht?
Täglich.
Eine Packung am Tag?
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur bei Feierlichkeiten.
Was trinken Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht, was es auf der Feier gibt, wenn es eine Feier gibt, Bier oder Wein.
Wein, was es gibt?
Ja, Wein.
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Bei Gelegenheit, Feierlichkeiten, die ich nicht muss, und das war mein Gehirn.
Das ist auch ein Problem, weil ich ganz selten bin.
Nur bei Feierlichkeiten.
Das ist einmal im Jahr oder zweimal im Jahr.
Das müssen Sie dann nicht fragen.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Was ist Ihre Familie?
Ich bin beruflich.
Ich bin Bürokaufrau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Leiden Ihre Eltern Erkrankungen?
Ich bin ein Bürokaufrau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Leiden Ihre Eltern Erkrankungen?
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Meine Eltern?
Meine Mutter ist schon lange verstorben.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Und mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck.
Und Glaucom.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja.
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Nein.
Ich bin ein Bürokaufrau.
Ist sie gesund?
Nein.
Sie hat auch Diabetes und Bluthochdruck.
Sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Ja.
Seit wann?
Zehn Jahre.
Bezogen Sie Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja.
Seit wann?
Ich habe mich alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie eine Frage?
Oder möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Luftnot.
Frau Doktor, ich will, dass die Luftnot weggeht.
Ich bin kaum noch belastbar.
Ich habe bis vor vier Wochen gearbeitet.
Ich bin jetzt ständig krankgeschrieben.
Ich habe noch nicht getroffen.
Und ich bin jetzt ständig krankgeschrieben.
Ich möchte wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ich möchte wieder normal meinen Haus weit machen können.
Das kann ich nicht mehr.
Und ich bin ja auch noch nicht so alt.
Und ich möchte gerne auch wissen, ob ich jetzt am Krankenhaus zu bleiben muss.
Oder nicht?
Ja.
Es ist zu früh, um etwas zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie
Herzversorgung
haben.
Was habe ich?
Herzversorgen.
Was ist ein Herzversorgen?
Meinen Sie Herzversorgen?
Ja, Herzversorgen.
Versorgen heißt jemandem etwas versorgen.
Okay, versorgen.
Herzversorgen.
Ja, Herzversorgen.
Und es funktioniert?
Das ist nicht gut funktioniert.
Aber das ist nur mein Verdachtdiagnose.
Und meine Verdachtdiagnose ist für mich der Tegel.
Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen auch etwas Volute abnehmen.
Ein EKG schreiben lassen.
Herzultraschall durchführen.
Eine Röntgenaufnahme machen lassen.
Nach einer Ergebnis sind keine Hine Bescheid geben.
Was die genau haben,
die Sie nicht mehr haben.
Das ist eine Ergebnis.
Ich möchte Ihnen Bescheid geben,
was Sie genau haben, wie wir weiter vorgehen werden.
Okay, das hört sich nach sehr viel Arbeit noch an.
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Bitte schön.
Müssten Sie in der Nacht Wasser lassen?
Ja, das haben wir gesagt.
Ich muss nachts oft aufstehen zum Wasser lassen.
Und fühlen Sie sich
besonders in der Lesserzeit
in der Zeit,
erschöpft oder abgeschlafen?
Ich habe gesagt,
ich kann nicht mehr treppensteigen,
weil ich Luftnot habe.
Natürlich bin ich erschöpft.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen
oder
Ähnliches beschwerden?
Ähnliches beschwerden.
Es kann sein,
ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich mein Herz mehr spüre,
wenn ich zum Beispiel mich etwas anstrengen.
Also ich kann ja meinen ganz normalen
Haushalt nicht mehr machen, verstehen Sie?
Und wenn ich mich leicht anstrengen
körperlich, dann habe ich schon
das Gefühl,
dass ich mein Herz spüre.
Vielleicht ist das Herzrasen.
Ich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen, aber so etwas in der Art.
Danke.
Bitte?
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen
oder Herzklopfen?
Ich habe gerade gefragt,
das ist nur, wenn ich mich körperlich anstrengen.
Ist das eine kardiologische
Ursorgeunterzucht
oder?
Nein, das ist nicht gefragt.
Ich war nicht beim,
ich war die letzte.
Also ich habe einen Kardiologen,
da gehe ich eigentlich
jährlich hin.
Dieses Jahr war ich aber noch nicht.
Okay.
Können wir Herzrasen, Herzklopfen,
oder?
Natürlich, dann keine Fragen mehr sind, gerne.
Guten Tag Frau Oberanstin.
Mein Name ist Gümmüsch.
Heute habe ich
einen neuen Patientin.
Darf ich über Sie berichten?
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Jawohl, bitte.
Legen Sie los.
Ja, danke schön.
Meine Patientin
berichtet dort.
Frau Ort ist
60 Jahre alt.
Ein Meter
75 groß,
98 Kilogramm schwer.
Ich stelle sich bei uns
heute wegen, seit
14 Tagen
Diszipline
Husten mit
Auswurf
vor.
Wir stehen da.
Vor.
Um eine
Beinordern hat 10 kg in nächstes Zeit zugenommen.
Und sie hat Polyurea seit 40 Tagen.
Aber keine Schmerzen, keine Blut im Urin.
Sie hat nicht, dass sie Polyurea hat.
Das ist nicht richtig.
Polyurea heißt ja, dass sie ständig Wasser lassen muss.
Aber sie hat gesagt, sie muss nachts viel Wasser lassen.
Und das hat einen anderen Ausdruck.
Sie hat eine Nekturier, aber keine Polyurea.
Polyurea lässt sehr viel Wasser.
Sie haben aber auch nicht gefragt, wie viel Wasser sie immer lassen muss.
Wenn sie Wasser lässt, ob das viel oder etwas wenig.
Oft ist es, wenn sie Wasser lässt.
Das wissen wir ja nicht.
Sie haben aber keine Nekturier.
Sie hat nicht viel Wasser lassen.
Es gibt keine Herzrasen,
bei Anstrengung.
Das hat sie gesagt, bei körperlicher Anstrengung.
Wenn sie sich körperlich anstrengt,
dann empfindet sie das so, als hätte sie Herzrasen.
Sie leidet.
Sie hat die Ebene Melutus arteriallipertoni.
Schon langem Jahr.
Sie hat Herzinfarkt gelitten vor fünf Jahren.
Und Herz, Katheter und...
Stopp.
Ja.
Sie hat arteriallipertoni und Diabetes seit langem Jahr.
Haben Sie gesagt, richtig?
Ja.
Seit langem Jahr geht nicht.
Seit langem, können Sie sagen, oder seit vielen Jahren?
Okay.
Seit langem Jahr ist ein Jahr.
Seit vielen Jahren. Am besten, am einfachsten.
Okay.
Sie hat Herzinfarkt vor fünf Jahren gelitten.
Litten oder gehabt ist egal.
Herz, Katheter wurde duckefurt und mit Stunt behandelt.
Sie nimmt ASS und Amlodipin,
fünf Milligramm morgens und abends,
Ram-April, fünf Milligramm morgens und abends.
Metronidazol.
Was ist Metronidazol?
Nicht Metronidazol, Metformin.
Nicht Metronidazol, sondern Metformin.
Sondern mit Formin. Genau.
Formin 1 und 1.000, 2 Mal.
Und Atolvastatin 40 Milligramm, 1 Mal 1.
Abends, hat sie gesagt. Sie nimmt es abends.
Sie hat keine Allergie. Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Sie hat keine Am besten Mehrzahl. Sie hat keine Allergien.
Keine Allergien. Sie ist seit fünf Jahren nicht Raucherin.
Aber früher hat sie 25 Jahre geraucht.
Sie ist seit fünf Jahren nicht Raucherin.
Sie hat 25 Jahre geraucht.
Sie hat eine Schwester.
Sie ist seit fünf Jahren nicht Raucherin.
Sie hat typische Symptome dafür, Distne, Orthopne und Sanchliogramm zu genomen und Nectury und Beine da.
Okay, da will ich Sie jetzt mal was fragen.
Haben Sie die Patientin gefragt, Sie hat gesagt, Sie hat geschwollene Beine, ob die Beine beidseitsgeschwollen sind oder einseitig geschwollen sind?
Haben Sie die Patientin gefragt?
Ich habe sie nicht gefragt.
Okay, das ist aber auch wichtig.
Warum? Weil sie hat Luftnot und sie hat gesagt, sie hat geschwollene Beine.
Warum? Weil manchmal hat man geschwollene Beine, aber dann muss man fragen und gucken, sind beide Beine gleich dick oder ist ein Bein dicker als das andere?
Warum?
Tarpete kann sein.
Warum? Weil dann wer Differenzialdiagnostisch zu Herzen und Suizidienz, was ja Gold richtig ist, würde dann nämlich eine ganz andere Diagnose
als Verdachtdiagnose, als erste Verdachtdiagnose.
Wir haben ja viele Verdachtdiagnose.
Was wäre dann die erste Verdachtdiagnose, wenn ein Bein dicker ist als das andere?
Was wäre dann Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Lungonatrielambulie macht denn die Lungenartiellenambulie, wenn sie das jetzt seit vier Wochen hat, die ganze Sache.
Und wenn sie diese Lungenartiellenambulie vier Wochen lang verschleppt hat, die ganze Zeit, dann hat sie auch irgendwann eine Rechtszeltinsuffizienz,
dann hat sie auch Gewichtszunahme. Verstehen Sie, was ich meine?
Aber das hätten Sie sowieso wahrscheinlich gesagt als Differenzialdiagnose.
Was für Differenzialdiagnosen kommen noch in Frage?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber ich sollte Hormontherapie fragen.
Na ja, das ist jetzt nicht so meiner Meinung nach so so essentiell für diese für diese Sachen.
Also das Wichtigste haben Sie ja gesagt, es kann sein, dass das eine Herzunzuffizienz ist einfach.
Ja, und trotzdem sein, da sagen wir, die Verdachtdiagnose Lungenambulie darf man nicht.
Sess, tamam, ich gehe.
Ich gehe, Sess, ich kann nicht.
Ich gehe, ich gehe.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Was könnte, was, was, was könnte es noch sein?
Ähm, Pynomonie kann sein.
Genau, vor allen Dingen, was kann es noch sein?
Was wir momentan immer alle durchmachen, was kann es noch sein?
Pynomonie, Pynomonie, Pynomonie.
COPD kann es auch sehr gut, super kann auch sein, richtig ab, und was noch,
dass man auch noch nicht probiert, kann auch probiert sein.
richtig ab und was noch, dass man auch noch nicht vorwitnt, kann doch vorwit sein.
Vorwit. Ja, ganz auch sein. Ja, sehr gut, genau so. Noch etwas. Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie so ein Reiz
Husten hat. Passt das zur Herzinsuffizienz? Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie Reiz Husten hat.
Passt das zur Herzinsuffizienz? Ja, vielleicht. Warum? Ich weiß nicht, ich erinnere mich nicht.
Kann ja ganz normal sein, im Rahmen der Stauung, kann ja alle Dekompensation,
Prümonalvenöse, Stauung, Herzfehler zählen, kann ja sein. Das Schleim ist jetzt auch ein
bisschen Blut mit dabei. Es kann ja sein, dass das da durchkommt. Was, ich habe extra,
noch etwas extra genannt? Ja, die nimmt Ramipril und Amlodipil, Asehemma,
Asehemma versorgt Husten. Katan, ich habe extra Ramipril gesagt, damit sie das erwähnen.
Es kann auch sein, das ist natürlich Ramipril Bedingtes. Ich meine, sie ist komplex krank,
aber man muss das im Hinterkopf behalten und das mal umstellen dann, weil sie hat ja so
einen Reißfusten, kann es auch ausgelöst haben. Die Agnostik haben sie ja schon gesagt,
sie würden dann Labor machen, EKG, was auch, was alles war gut, was nicht, was man noch hätte
machen sollen, haben wir eben schon gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, zwischen drin, ich muss Pause machen,
ich habe Lustnot. Damit habe ich ihm signalisiert, mir geht es nicht gut. Was müssen
Sie spätestens dann machen? Ich erinnere mich nicht. Dann müssen Sie spätestens dann sagen,
wir machen jetzt mal Pause, ich mache mal Sauerstoffsetigung, ich nehme Sie an den Monitor,
wir schreiben mal ein EKG, bla bla bla. Ich muss sich unterbrechen und sagen,
wenn der Patient nicht gut geht, wenn sie keine Luft kriegt, würde ich das auf jeden Fall machen.
Und das andere ist, das kommt auf jeden Fall immer sehr gut in der Prüfung an,
wenn man das sagt und das andere ist, und das andere ist, was ganz wichtig ist,
ist, macht bei dieser Patientin vor allen Dingen, wenn sie Luftnot hat, es geht ihr nicht gut. Sie hat
aber keine Brustschmerzen. Sie hat gesagt, es ist wie ein Stein auf der Brust. Das haben Sie
jetzt die ganze Zeit nicht erwähnt. Sie hat gesagt, manchmal, wenn sie sich anstrengt,
hat sie das Gefühl, da ist ein Stein auf der Brust. Das bedeutet auf Patientensprache,
ich habe das extra gesagt, ich habe Druck auf der Brust. Die Patienten sagen nicht immer,
ich habe Druck auf der Brust. Ich habe enge Gefühle. Das Wort kennen die gar nicht. Manche
Patienten sagen, es ist so, als ob ein Elefant drauf sitzt, es ist als ob ein Stein drauf wäre,
es als auf ein Auto über mich gefahren ist. Und ich habe extra gesagt, es ist wie ein Stein. Das
heißt, sie hat auch Druck auf der Brust. Jetzt müssen Sie überlegen. Sie hat gesagt,
sie hatte schon mal einen Herzinfarkt, sie hat jetzt Druck auf der Brust, nur bei Belastung,
aber sie ist Diabetikerin. Was bedeutet das? Das bedeutet, dass sie jetzt vor vier Wochen auch einen
neuen zweiten Herzinfarkt gehabt haben kann und dass sie im Rahmen des Herzinfarktes eine
Herzinsowizenz entwickelt hat. Das heißt, sie müssen Pause machen und ein EKG schreiben auch.
Ein Zwölfkanaleckg, ein Zwölfkanaleckg, um zu gucken, ob sie den infarkt hat. Und
bei dieser Patientin ist es tatsächlich so, dass sie reinfaziert hat. Vor ein paar Wochen, sie
hat das nicht gemerkt, weil sie Diabetikerin ist. Deswegen hat sie eine Herzinsowizenz entwickelt.
Und jetzt machen Sie natürlich, haben Sie Labor gemacht, was machen Sie im Labor?
Gerinnungsparameter. Fangen Sie mich auf alle Unwichtigste jetzt bei ihr. Fangen Sie mich den
wichtigen Dingen an, mit der Verdachtdiagnose.
Herzinsowizenz, Troponin, CKMB und Gerinnungsparameter.
Noch nicht bei Gerinnungsparameter. Wir sind immer noch bei Klien-Tschischemmie. Was noch?
Was machen wir?
Laktat beidrogenas.
Ja, LDH auch. Aber was machen wir? Hier im Kopf, Sie haben gesagt,
Diagnose-Lungnen-Bully. Was kommt als nächstes?
Gerinnungsparameter.
Doch, LDH. Entschuldigung.
Ich seh nicht.
Okay.
Was noch?
Nein, die dritte Differenzialdiagnose war was.
Dritte COPD, Pynomony.
Laboid.
COVID.
COPD.
Entschuldigungswerte.
Ja, ja.
Blutbett.
Die Rindung geht im Herde.
Und was noch?
Ich fehl mir noch.
Was Sie haben gesagt, Hauptdiagnose ist.
Herzunsoficienz.
Was machen wir dann?
Welchen Wert?
ProBNP.
NT ProBNP.
BNP.
Ah!
Rueda, Radeologe,
hat die Handyschanomoisery.
Herzunsoficienz BNP ist eins.
BNP zeigt an, einfach,
das ist ein naturalerities PPD.
Das wird ausgeschüttet, wenn das Herz,
wenn das Herz überladen ist an Flüssigkeit
und die Pumpkraft nicht mehr gut ist.
Das ist ein Zeichen für eine Herzunsoficienz.
Rechtsetzunsoficienz, linksetzunsoficienz wissen wir nicht,
aber das Herz ist ein Zeichen für eine Herzunsoficienz.
Um herauszufinden, welches Herz nicht gut funktioniert,
machen wir den Herzultraschall danach.
BNP ist super wichtig.
ProBNP.
Herzunsoficienz.
Deshalb tadi hat man gesagt,
die D differentialdiagnosolone cyst Willi,
jetzt haben wir alles.
Was machen Sie als Nächstes?
Blutgassinganalyse haben Sie schon gemacht?
gleichzeitig machen, weil wenn sie einmal den Patienten pieksen, abnehmen Blut, dann machen
sie gleich beides. Und was machen Sie als Untersuchung dann noch? Urin, Analys, Echokardiografie.
Genau, um zu gucken, ob das Herz gut pumpt oder nicht, Wandbewegungsstörungen und so weiter,
Herz klappen und so weiter und so weiter. Genau, sehr gut. Der Patient hat ein sehr,
sehr hohes Probenp über 10.000, hat eine Pumpfunktion von 35 Prozent, das heißt höhergradig eingeschränkt.
Und der Patient hat ein Troponin von 1000 und mit CK von 500 und eine MB von 200. Was machen Sie?
Troponin erhöht, CKMB erhöht, ja. Emi, vielleicht, Emi kann sein. Genau, das muss man im EKG nicht sehen,
das EKG kann ja auch unaufwändig sein, kann ein ENSTEMI sein. Dann müssen wir jedenfalls spätestens
jetzt einen Kardiologen anrufen und sagen, ich habe einen Patienten mit Caracac, hat jetzt Luftnot und
hat jetzt Infarktkonstellation im Labor, also ein typisches Labor, kann man sagen, und dann gucken
die sich das an und entscheiden das. Aber er muss dann natürlich herzkartiert werden,
vielleicht nicht akut, aber es muss gemacht werden. Weil es ist wahrscheinlich,
ist das bei diesem Patienten ein nicht frischer Myokartinfarkt, weil Troponin ist schon sehr
hoch. Wenn die LDH, wenn man sich die LDH angucken würde, wäre die LDH auch hoch. Dann
spricht das alles dafür, dass es nicht mehr ganz frisch ist. Und da kann man erst mal gucken,
dass der Patient erst mal Lasix bekommt, damit die Luft besser wird. Weil im Karteat
natürlich müssen sich flach liegen, können die ja nicht, wenn die akut Luftnot haben.
Und dann am nächsten Tag wird die Herrskartier der Untersuchung dann gemacht. Beim akuten
Herzinfarkt ist das nicht so, da muss das sofort gemacht werden. Aber bei einem,
ein paar Tage alten, nicht mehr ganz frisch im Infarkt, kann man warten. Okay? Ja, also ich muss,
also das Erzählen war super, wirklich muss ich sagen, die deutsche Sprache ist super. Ich hätte
nicht gedacht, dass sie Radiolorien sind schon mal, das war alles sehr gut. Aber beim BNP,
ich bin da, das war das wirklich ehrlich. Das ist heute eine Sache lernen, BNP lernen.
Okay? Genau. Und ansonsten fand ich das eigentlich ganz gut, ehrlich gesagt, oder was sagen die anderen?
Das war doch, das hat sie sehr gut gemacht. Aber es war sehr, wirklich sehr gut fand es bei ihr,
dass sie auch dann das Ramipril gedacht hat. Es war auch sehr gut. War gut. Gut, sehr, sehr gut.
Ich muss leider, ich muss leider, ich muss leider auflegen.